I need you to become the head man
we have not one but two credit sequences
from the end of ant-man plus we'll let
you know how they fit into the rest of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I'm drew Coolidge's mess up my own neck
are these the best and credit scenes
that Marvel's ever made we'll find out
sash tag news Paul Rudd is a great
addition to the Marvel Universe how
could you resist that puppy-dog face and
puppy-dog charm I couldn't and didn't I
loved ant-man but if we're gonna talk
about it before Warren because there's
definite spoilers ah sorry the first off
is a mid credit sequence here we see
Hank Pym and hope Van Dyne played by
Michael Douglas in Evangeline Lilly
hanging out in Kim's lab the
relationship hasn't been the best since
Hanks wife and hopes mom died and hope
help kick Hank out of his own company
but in the end you can see that made up
he tells her she's finally ready to
follow in her mother's footsteps the
camera reveals a suit which will allow
hope to become wasp hopes response to
the suit is the same as mine it's about
damn time
now wasp like ant-man can shrink to a
very small size but also fly around
using wasp like wings and obviously she
can fire bioelectric energy blasts but
really who can according to Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige we have
plans for her in the future and we can
see that not so subtly in this film
you're right Kevin that wasn't subtle
but I'm glad it wasn't I'm excited for
more wasp for what wasp is a huge
character in the Marvel comic universe
and it's eventually Lily from lost atom
a dream wasp fighting a smoke monster
wasp fighting a terrible ending to a
show you love there's endless
possibilities the final sequence is
definitely worth waiting for
here's what Marvel did something crazy
they cancelled their original plans for
the final sequence the original sequence
was supposed to be just a funny Bend
credit scene like the schwarmann scene
from The Avengers then while he was
watching Captain America Civil War he
noticed this scene and literally said
whoa that could be the tag and boom that
scene is now in a movie whoa
in the movie ant-man Falcon was fighting
alongside Paul Rudd and in this scene
from civil war he's back alongside
Captain America himself Chris Evans they
come across the bound and captured
Winter Soldier aka Bucky Falcon ass hey
you want me to get Tony Stark Captain
America was like no no I don't want that
of course Captain America doesn't want
Tony Stark's help they're going
head-to-head in Civil War
Falcon replies I know a guy he sure does
he's got a buddy named ant-man he was
fighting alongside the whole time so
look for Paul Rudd to show up in Civil
War and Beyond here we go all right that
is it for the post-credits scenes and
take it from me I stayed in the theater
so long after the credits I thought
there was a third post-credit scene
turns out they just started the movie
over again so hit subscribe for more
Marvel DC and other comic book movie
coverage check out our breakdown of the
Marvel rival DC's Suicide Squad and
check out the Avengers post-credits
explanation here with a very attractive
host who I was insinuating it was me Oh
so please share this video or subscribe
to get answers to all the questions you
really want to know like how does Paul
Rudd cut his hair so casually messy yet
put together also comment with your
thoughts do you have any other theories
about how ant-man ties into the MCU
do we miss something let me know I'm
drew Coolidge thanks for watching but
make sure to stay put for our post
credits sequence I told them is going to
be a post-credits sequence
is the world ready for this
it's time